so we're dealing with
um I call it billion scale deduplication
it's a deduplication uh on one of our
major data sets uh and it's a billion
scale which poses real challenges
um and that's what I'm going to talk
about it's a I wish it was a trivia
solution but it's not
so who am I my name is Idan
um nice Family Guy uh three kids
um basically or by education I'm an
economist turned data scientist around
five years ago and love it very much
um kind of a gig like a coding gig also
volunteering in let's see or NGO for
almost a decade and number one fan of
number one singer in Israel mini bagel
so what is the motivation for our
building scale the duplication for the
the duplication itself
so this is like a sample uh of course a
mock-up sample of our data set so what
we see is that we've got multiple
records uh per one entity if you can see
uh like Dan Richmond and Eiden Richmond
and like Smiley and such and the
information for a given entity is
gathered around many records okay and
they're not like
a real duplications exact duplications
and we've got hundreds of millions of
them if not billion uh plus so uh this
is the challenge and ended the
resolution in general is
um like the technique to link those
scattered records and to link and
identify that these are these records
are the same entity okay although name
can be a bit fuzzy or a bit change so
um
this is the the name of let's say the
category for it and the challenges that
we've got are first of all fuzzy
matching so we can see the name can
differ a bit like in character level you
can see this one starts with an i and
this one starts with an e
and we've got the non-latin or accents
accented letters
um could be different we've got semantic
matching so let's say data scientist and
data engineer we could say these are the
same semantically or at least close
semantically although these are
different strings and we've got
information extraction for instance from
the email field we can see like in this
we have a smiley but I can
but I can extract the name from the
email or the company from the email
domain
and doing that for billions of Records
or hundreds of millions
um and that is uh an issue
so we need to do it efficiently we can
just go and do it one by one compare
every record to all other records right
so this is a simple case let's say I'm
taking the first record the one gray
above and start to compare it with all
the others Computing some distance
scores let's say I don't know levention
distance or whatever
um distance you can use
um but this doesn't scale right because
if I'm doing every record against all
other records this is like a major
complexity and for 100 million records
for instance and we've got more of them
so it's like five quadrillion which is
15 zeros after
comparisons this doesn't scale you can
do it
so one of the uh let's say uh
fundamental uh or the common methods to
handle such it's a complexity is to do
blocking right or let's say clustering
or reducing the search space so I'm not
going to compare one to or the other I'm
going to compare it for a small subset
that I identify that I had identified
that they can be
um similar right so for instance let's
say I'm using the initials let's take
the first letter of the first name and
the first letter of the last name and
I'm grouping them by those so I've got
like IR ir and I'm comparing them both
okay so each record I compare only to
the other records in the same block or
cluster whatever
and we can see this is sub-optimal right
and even if you've got large data so the
blocks will be even large right and if
I'm splitting it for many blocks so it
won't be efficient
so we need something better right
something more advanced so here I uh
let's say enter A and N which is not
artificial neural network it's
approximate nearest neighbors and it's
approximate because let's say unlike k n
or so we're not doing an exhaustive
search again comparing and searching for
the whole distance between each record
to your ladder so we're doing something
approximate
so we sacrificed some accuracy but we
gain a lot of uh let's say performance
uh and speed so we can actually scale it
up
before moving forward with a n just a
quick interlude on uh embeddings right
or let's say representation and
so for instance here I'm taking a job
title which is part of our data right
job title of a contact
and what we can see here for instance
it's a clustering we did uh embeddings
for job titles so similar titles will be
closer in space and this is like a 2d
projection of the entire space let's say
I've got 100 Dimensions so this is just
2D and we can see similar titles are
similar closer to each other so you've
got like human resources and those
yellows so we've got the Taylor
underwriter bookkeeping like more
Finance or banking stuff
and let's say teller will be closed more
to bookkeeping and not let's say
storyteller which is text wise can be
closer but Storyteller and bank teller
completely different things right so
Storyteller will be let's say
Off the Grid here not not near
and what we will do in an answer we're
searching in that space
for each Vector for the nearest
neighbors of it so
the search results that we will get is
as good as our embedding so if you've
got like poor embeddings or poorer
presentations or search results will be
poor as well
in terms of similarity measures most of
it uh we use the command so we got your
creating distance or cosine distance so
constant distance is just Computing the
angle between the vectors and doesn't
take care of the magnitude of the vector
so uh it will come handy later
and for instance if you look at those
alien masks or tweets so one says like
one word dog and no highs no laws only
dog so if you computed your car distance
which is the set similarity so we've got
only one common word right dog in the
the Jakarta distance is quite low right
because only one word among like seven
unique words but let's think of it like
fundamentally or semantically those
tweets are quite similar right they talk
about dog this is what's important so um
this is the importance of the semantic
order representation of what we're
looking for
so the main algorithms we use for a n uh
and those are the most common that you
can use in all these state-of-the-art
algorithms are based on those mainly on
like uh IVF and the hnsw so we've got
lsh which is I think the oldest one
and it has a lot of literature on it and
a lot of
enhancements and developments on it uh
it's it's a bit uh sub-optimal comparing
to the others and less used but the idea
of lsh
is that it is local locality sensitive
action
what it means so usually when when we
are using hash functions right when we
want to minimize collisions right we
want to Hash stuff that they will be
separate
and in locality sensitive hashing we
want to Hash stuff and closer
um let's say entities should be hashed
together right and not separately so we
want to increase collisions for the
closer stuff for closer entities
the other one is the inverted file index
and the hnsw will go for them further
so for lsh uh for instance we can see
here I'm not gonna dive into it
it's not the main topic of it so I'm
just going to go briefly on it so you
can get the the concepts but there are a
lot of good resources also I've got a
slide at the end for instance this one
or this illustration I took from
Pinecone they've got like a whole
Learning Center on the website the one
of they're like a commercial company
that does a vector database
and they've got good resources it's very
good resources
so if you've got signature a let's say
so this is Elon Musk first width and you
divide it to sub vectors you hash them
and you've got you hash them into
separate buckets
now we've got signature B
and you can see here that in some of the
buckets in some of this sub it's a hash
functions let's go for different buckets
but on the red one it goes for the same
bucket and that's how we know that we
flag those two signatures or those two
texts or vectors whatever
as comparison candidates okay and this
is what we want to do so we want to take
two records that we've got let's go back
for our initial database okay of
contacts of Records remember the
enrichment either enrichment whatever
so we want to flag two records as
candidates
and later on we will go over those
candidates and perform a more deeper uh
comparison to see if they are indeed the
same entity okay we don't want to do
this deeper comparison for our records
we can't
so this is the
um let's say the purpose of a n right to
reduce the search space that we're
performing
hnsw is a graph based algorithm and what
it does so it constructs a graph when
you train it or build it and then
whenever you've got the query vector and
you want to find its nearest neighbors
so it's reverse the graph and you can
find the nearest neighbor the problem is
that when you've got like wrong path so
it takes a lot of time that's why uh
some smart guy invented
find out about a record navigable small
world graphs and what it does so it
allows for each layer to go let's say
the top layer is doing like big lips
across the space so you can every time
you go down a layer you go into finer
detail or finer distances
and that way you can like skip very fast
from here to here and find the nearest
Neighbors
the next one is the inverted file index
in in this case we take the space we
divide it to Sales it's based on varoni
cells over one diagrams and the property
of those cells let's go for here so each
um
each point in space for instance if it
lies inside those red cell so it means
that it is the most closer to the
centroid of the cell all right like
let's think of it like k-means right so
each point in the red cell is the the
one that most close to the distance
right and or the other centroids so what
we're doing we're dividing the space to
those cells and now when I want to find
out for instance here
I've got this Square vector and who are
the nearest neighbors for that Vector I
don't need to search for the whole space
for the all records in all space I'm
just looking at the records inside the
the same cell right but what happens if
I'm looking for that query and I've got
a nice candidate here right so it is
closer for instance here instead of the
one from inside itself so you can Define
there's like a n probe parameter that
you define how many adjacent cells you
need to look for so you can look not
just inside its own cell but also in the
cells near and of course if we will
choose like large and probe it will take
more time and if you choose like n Pro
Infinity it is the same as doing like
exhaustive k n right
in terms of comparison between the
algorithms so there's there are
trade-offs right so for instance uh hnsw
takes a lot of memory which is a problem
with when we're dealing with large data
sets
um but it is quite fast also IVF it is
quite fast this is like milliseconds per
query and of course what you say your
mileage may vary between data sets and
stuff
if you compare it for an exotic
exhaustive search and this is only for
one billion data set one million points
so we see a huge Improvement in search
time and this is very very crucial if
you want to do it for hundreds of
millions of Records right so
um this is very
um
critical
just back here so what we want to
balance we want to balance the speed
and the memory and we want a good record
right we call if you go exhaustive so it
will be one because this is you search
for everything if you go approximate so
we sacrifice some recall but we gain
speed foreign
that we're doing right so
[Music]
these are let's say the four main steps
so the first step that everyone is aware
of is like a lot of cleanup a lot of
preparation
doing
um text embeddings and embedding the
name the company name the job title and
whatever data that we've got for each
record
the second step and I think this is the
most uh crucial one or the most
stuff that is not usual is the a n one
right so we need to find good match
candidates
and after we find those candidates we
can go and pass it for a classified
so the classifier as I said
is something that takes uh
performs a deeper comparison of the
records so if I'm doing the a n or the
approximate on the embedded vectors I
might use some like the embedded factors
does not uh it's not perfect for
comparison so when I go deeper I can
compare like two strings with different
distance measures I can do a lot of uh
let's say more computational uh costly
operations but I can do it for a lot of
comparisons right because it takes time
so you need to minimize the search space
that I'm passing for the classifier and
like future engineering Etc
and the last one after I'm finding
matches so the classifier let's say the
classifier gets 300 candidates
and then it says like okay only two are
a good match so some might be uh similar
so for instance I get done and I don't
know
um
right good thanks
those are similar right ID and uh oh
whatever but the classifier will say
this is not the same person right I know
that Idan is different than you do it's
not the same person so the classifier
give me uh should give me a better
result and then it is if it's passed for
the uh merge and the marriage goes and
take all those different entities like
the table I showed you at the beginning
and merge them all to one canonical
contact so now instead of having five
records for done and getting only one
record because this is one entity not
five
so the inn and Israel I think this is
the most critical part of it
we need to choose the stack what we're
going to use so there are different
tools
um
there are different packages
and we need to choose so we experimented
with some of them
um
we looked at like record linkage and
spring and data sketch this is lsh those
are all like python packages
some of them are not really a n as I
showed you before so I'm just doing
Simple blocking like I showed you with
the initials I think the one that uses a
n with like state of the art or Spotify
annoy package and uh hnswd and FIS which
is like a Facebook AI similar research
and our requirements was that we don't
want to rely on in memory because we're
dealing with a large data set that
doesn't fit in Ram right so I need a
package that doesn't rely that I have
everything on my pandas data frame and I
can pass it to it I need something that
knows how to handle batches or whatever
and that that doesn't fit in Ram
also I need something that support
updates
all right so
um let's say I'm doing the due
duplication today tomorrow I'm getting
new data and I want to update or check
this new data on my current indexes and
not do the whole process all over again
from the beginning so I need to support
updates or deletions
and it needs to be fast of course that's
for instance why data sketch lsh is not
suitable just too slow when the data
passes like one two million records
so after a bit of experimentation we
decided to go with files in the IVF
algorithm
that's the the tools that uh the list or
let's say the minimum overhead I think
also uh Hanoi is a good tool and the
hnsw also it's a good algorithm and a
good tool but it requires more treating
and more uh playing around if you want
to
use it with uh let's say out of memory
um
setting
and files also have a GPU implementation
which can give you a big speed up uh for
my initial uh place or playground you
get like a 10 free time speed up which
is uh also very crucial
and just to know about the space so you
can see that lately in the past I don't
know a year or so or even less the next
six months so a lot of like elastic
search and open search is time to put a
m capabilities into their systems into
the search engine and there is a growing
Shield of let's say Vector databases
that allow you to have projectors do
similar research and all kinds of those
uh stuff and should work like out of the
box we didn't try those uh commercial
Solutions but you can see them here and
they might be good I don't know
so the first phase of uh doing the IVF
so we need to train or we need to fit
the space right so we need to find those
centroids of the cells so later on we
can pass those records like the vectors
of the records and it will assign them
to those different cells right you said
we need to reduce the search space so we
need to train it but for fitting it I
can't use the entire data set right so I
need to to find like a sample a good
sample to train it on and a good sample
is not just take the first one million
right because the first one million can
be only names that starts with a right
so I need to find something
representative the same distribution is
my whole data so
um it needs to be limited by size so you
can fit into RAM so I just took the
first um like as before the initial the
first letter or first name first letter
of last name and also for the company
name or job title so I I get like a
couple of thousands of uh let's say
those bins and I limited the size of the
data so it can be like just one gigabyte
and it can be uh tricked uh and this is
how I trained or fitted the space and
again what I wanted to accomplish is to
have a representation for the whole
Space
um that's what I cared about
and the second step is to draw and start
indexing those vectors right so this is
the core element the index and then when
I'm having like a new record
like I'm getting a new record and I'm
feeding it into the uh into the
algorithm you can tell me who is uh that
record nearest neighbors so we need to
index all the neighbors all the the
records and I think who
among you that use like elasticsearch or
so so it works similarly the same it
does indexing it index the data and then
it looks for the nearest Neighbors
uh and again the data is too big for Ram
so what I did I took the parquet file
right the further that spark saves and
just went file by file and you can see
the file size is manageable of course
for Ram and pandas so I installed to add
it to the index and this is the way that
you can do it for the entire
um a lot of gigabytes of data and not
just in one go
also uh we need to consider for the
index size
because even I can add it in batches but
at the end I've got like an index file
or an index that we need to search uh
and all those packages or at least what
exists today just
use it like in memory so I need the
index itself to stay in memory doesn't
know how to uh to read it like on disk
or so there are some implementations but
uh again not open source
um so what I used is something that is
called Product quantization
and what it basically does so it takes
uh it's like a compression algorithm and
takes the vectors and it's kind of
compressed and I'm not going to go into
the details the in exact but it uh it's
like
divides the vector into uh parts and
then for each part it does some
clustering okay so for for the first
part it trains like a clustering
algorithm and then it stores a cluster
an ID of the cluster so it compresses
the data a lot and you can reduce the
index size
like a large magnitudes for instance
like a 3D gigabyte index file turn into
three gigabyte which is again more
manageable to use on in memory right so
uh and as the data grows this is
something crucial again comes at the
expense of accuracy right so no free
lunch
another thing that uh
we encountered is the necessity to use
let's say fusioned or concatenated
vectors
we can
embed names separately so the embeddings
as a show though like job titles as I
showed you before but if I'm gonna look
now I've got a let's say Kobe coin right
it's a quite common name and I'm going
to look okay who are the um the
neighbors of kobikon give me all the
original records of kobecon I will get
like many many many many some of them
are not relevant because I'm not looking
for hobby coin in general right I'm
looking for a copycoin in a certain
company or a certain job title right
because those are the similar the
similar records of it so uh this is what
I care about so what we did we took the
vectors of the name let's say 100
Dimensions or 160 in that case and I
concatenated them one time with the
company vector and one time with the job
title Vector so I ended up with two
distinct vectors of 260 the
dimensionality and those are my indexes
so when I'm
let's say looking for the newest
neighbors I do it on two indexes nine
plus company and name plus job title
yeah
um
okay so um
if you can see the chart here so we see
the search speed right so we see um as
the number of vectors grow in my data
and this is the millisecond it takes to
to do the query so if I'm using the
product quantization let's say in
comparison for a flat exhaustive search
there's a huge speed up again
and I think the last thing before I go
into some questions
so it's about
um full record phase right because the
index product quantization everything
gets compressed everything goes in
memory this is fine but now I've got
like a billion
records data set and I just want to take
300 candidates for that query right so
get me 300 records from a billion uh
that is a billion records data set it
can take some time and if I do it not
just for one query right I want to do it
like for a lot of queries because I want
to go and Traverse all my data set quite
quickly and this is not uh just do read
parquet or read CSV or whatever for uh I
don't know dozens of a gigabyte it takes
time right so we need some fast solution
so we experimented with some uh uh the
solutions and the one that we find like
works best is using redis which is like
a key value in memory database and it's
like blazing fast and it is a it is
awesome
um I think we can skip that just to
leave some time for questions
about the classifier so this is the
feature engineering as I said we go
deeper into a comparison of the name
company title so I've got like a lot of
uh
a lot of string matching uh string
distance measures and this is again we
need to do some feature selection and we
did because it takes a lot of time and
some of them are redundant or correlated
and we need to count every millisecond
so um we chose only the the imported
ones and we also ditched the costing
similarity because it means also we need
to store or our original vectors in
redis which is uh very expensive so we
did ditch that
I used ex model and just for instance to
show you uh how a good match or what the
classifier can match so we see
um we've got a lot of it's a string
differences between those two records
and even the phones these are different
so just a simple naive solution would
never find this match right but using uh
all the stuff that I described so we
were able to match uh to match it
um okay this is just your weather
and just a quick recap so
um about the billion scale going bigger
scale what matters is that we need not
to rely on in-memory Solutions right we
need to go buy batches we need to go
product conversation we need to use fast
retrieval so it's not just like pandas
eye lock because it doesn't work when
you use it when you're dealing with
those massive data sets
um and I think that's it
global resources
[Applause]
and first one exit that if you want to
um yeah
I have two questions yeah One's Gonna
really try different similarity measures
first
can you elaborate distance and something
else that you saw some functions when
you actually extract the features that
you try to extract it using different
methods so doing like 11 stone distance
on the attacks themselves for example
and then doing something else like
having a membership
yeah I'm doing it in the classifier part
because I can't do it you can do
leverage and distance
for each record on all other hundreds of
Millions
yeah yeah so that's what I showed like
in the future engineering I did like
multiple features and then feature
selection to see which are available
today uh you have eight trees or gold
trees or whatever it's they are
implemented in 500 bits you can actually
even find them exact email that's why
they call proxy
it's approximate because
um it does some approximations you can
Traverse like do you can go with kd2
it's not scalable in terms of like let's
say milliseconds per query it will take
too much time on those massive data sets
at least that I'm aware of you can't go
exhaustive search
kd3 I don't think it's it's not a
approximate
um
I doubt it I will try but I really
really doubt it
okay
and first of all great talk and um first
two two questions and did you it looks
like a very complex Pipeline and the
noise the actual noise generation of
this uh of this data is sometimes users
are making mistakes and entering it so
I'm curious first of all if you what was
your benchmark your first and foremost
uh method to to compare to this complex
Pipeline and the second one why didn't
you use or if I understand it right
entity level information like compelling
companies comparing job titles and
comparing maybe names and addresses on a
different layer or dimension in order to
relax this problem
foreign
okay so uh as I said before comparing
companies some companies are small you
know like 10 employees so that might be
fine but let's say my previous company
there it's like you've got
hundreds of uh thousands uh not hundreds
tens of thousands of workers so I'm not
sure it is a feasible and also in that
manner you see a lot of uh
manifestations of the company name so
it's not just their Dell Technologies
their link there you've got a lot of
those fuzzy uh
um let's say differences so it's harder
but uh it might be a good idea I'll
think about it and for your first
question remind me hey what was your
benchmark oh The Benchmark yeah so um
basically it's not a label data set
right so my only label of things that I
can use to link to records are let's say
phone number or email and that's how I
train my uh classifier so I take records
that has the same phone number and
similar uh use some kind of a fuzzy
matching score similar score because
there are some phones that blend lines
that are shared among like 100 different
names different people so I can't tell
the classifier those are the same people
right I'm just leaning it from mistake
so that's how I like a quasi-label the
my data set and
um and that's how I built also my my
test setting and all but at the end you
need to uh manually inspected and also
in terms of that so we want to favor
Precision of a recall right because I
don't want to merge two uh distinct
entities I want to be safe and even if
I'm keeping the same entity on two
records it is better for me I think
business-wise than to merge entities
that are not the same
yeah I don't know how much time we've
got left for more persons so stop me
when you want
the goodness of a bending that's that's
a very good question I think uh in
general how do you test them weddings
yeah uh my answer right now is that uh I
just look at the results and it looks
good I haven't done some like let's say
methodical test or so to check it just
just works uh okay how did you combine
those two vectors that you measure in
Chrome navely concatenated and like
first second
um
just concatenate it and then used
question similarity because if you use
the creating distance so sometimes like
the first part of the embedding is
taking over because it's a different
embedding space so you need to use
cosine and not euclidean this is
important
thank you very much you can approach
later for uh
[Applause]